let's talk about bob saget because
nearly a week after he was laid to rest
bob's widow kelly rizzo is facing the
cameras to share their one-of-a-kind
love story
you guys are awesome have a great night
most comedians
after a stand-up gig they catch the last
flight home he said not bob bob wanted
to catch the first flight home he wanted
to be with you kelly and he said that
yeah
sorry um we valued every single second
that we had together
she's a great person and
most miraculously of all
she understands me
and he was just
the most caring
and kind and
thoughtful person he was so thoughtful
kelly broke down on both gma and today
and revealed bob's last words to her
moments after his final stand-up set i
think i said i love you dearly and he
said i love you endlessly and then he
said i said i can't wait to see you
tomorrow
did you think he was feeling okay during
during all this time all i'll say is
that he was
very happy and he was
just thrilled to be back out on the road
it's a gift to be able to be with people
and make them laugh
just six days ago bob's close friends
and castmates came together at a private
memorial i did speak and it was just
the whole thing as painful as it was was
beautiful to be surrounded by so many
people who loved him and who loved each
other he laughed and he spread joy john
mayer and jeff ross not only picked up
the car that bob left at lax et has
learned john arranged and paid for a
private plane to transport bob's body
home
he and candace cameron bray also helped
design these sweatshirts in bob's honor
benefiting the scleroderma research
foundation to find a cure for the
disease that killed his sister every
single one of them has been so kind and
supportive and they've just assured me
that they'll be there for me and i know
that would make bob very happy now kelly
also says she will keep bob's legacy
going to help fight scleroderma because
it meant so much to him
[Music]